[Música]
la federación internacional de natación
fina informó que aprobó su nueva
política de inclusión de género y acordó
por votación impedir que las nadadoras
trans compitan en carreras de élite
femeninas si pasaron por cualquier parte
del proceso de pubertad masculina la
nueva política de la fina aprobada en su
congreso general extraordinario con
motivo de los campeonatos del mundo que
se estaban disputando en budapest exige
que los competidores trans hayan
completado sus transiciones antes de los
212 años para así poder participar en
estas pruebas femeninas la fina también
intentará establecer una categoría
abierta en las competiciones para los
nadadores a cuya identidad de género sea
diferente a su sexo de nacimiento
saludamos entonces a nuestra primera
invitada del día es daniela muñoz
jiménez mujer trans deportista y médica
cirujana egresada de la facultad
mexicana de medicina de la universidad
de la salle gracias daniela por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 pues también con nosotros en
esta mesa de trabajo está nuestra
periodista deportiva humaniza g
qué tal cómo nos va buenos días gracias
por la invitación raúl a platicar y
desmitificar y de estabilizar un tema
tan tan tan importante así es daniela le
quiere preguntar entonces para ustedes
como comunidad trans que representa esta
decisión de la fina y además como los
afectan
la admira y no nada más como comunidad
trans porque esto es esto tiene que ver
también con derechos humanos se nos está
discriminando justamente ahí está esta
decisión que tomo este consejo además
que fue en una sesión extraordinaria y
se tomó una asesoría médica y con
decisión es completamente infértiles o
estériles tiene una asesoría de
profesionales que estamos en la doble
paz la doble paz es la asociación
mundial de médicos médicas médicos
tratantes de la salud trans hay un
montón de guías mencionan todo lo
contrario lo que acaban de decir esto
fue arbitrario fue completamente estéril
o repito y fue también
una decisión hondamente ignorante porque
ninguno de ellos claro es que conoce la
salud trans la ciencia de la medicina
trans entonces una decisión basada
completamente distintas prejuicios
el argumento principal que se esgrime es
que el haber pasado por la pubertad
masculina otorga una serie de ventajas
en lo que tiene que ver con fuerza con
desarrollo de masa muscular que
difícilmente se mitiga con terapias de
supresión hormonal que responden ustedes
a ese que es el argumento científico
principal que se
presenta para tomar esta decisión
claro definitivamente y realmente
desconocemos de dónde viene este
supuesto argumento científico porque lo
que nos dice la ciencia es que cuando
una persona que nació con testículos
independientemente de su edad
empieza un tratamiento hormonal su masa
ósea a lo largo obviamente no disminuye
pero si a lo ancho su masa muscular
también disminuye a una a una a un
volumen y a un tipo de fibras similar
muy similar o igual al de una persona
con ovarios
esto entre 2 y 3 años esto quiere decir
que una persona entre 2 y 3 años
independientemente de su edad
en las mismas
capacidades motrices y una persona que
nació con ovarios y todavía un poco peor
porque su masa ósea pesa un poco más que
la de los ovarios por lo largo pero con
menos musculatura
que la que podría tener ese o mover ese
esqueleto entonces se vuelve más
complejo es verdaderamente falaz que no
disminuye el músculo y el hueso claro
que disminuye usted menciona que si
disminuye con un tratamiento de dos a
tres años y hasta el momento la mayoría
de los organismos que habían permitido
la participación de atletas trans en el
deporte femenino indicaban un año de
tratamiento de supresión de hormonas
probablemente puede estar aquí la gran
diferencia en este tema
y es que es un año para las personas que
no son deportistas de alto rendimiento
claro está cuando sigues estimulando el
músculo el músculo disminuyendo una
manera un poco más lenta pero los dos o
tres años y esto es un promedio muy
estadístico bastante amplio en los dos o
tres años ya chiste la masa ósea ya
triste la masa muscular de una persona
con ovarios que también hace deporte de
alto rendimiento entonces
independientemente que hayan empezado a
los 12 o 13 años oa los 15 o 45 años el
resultado si va a disminuir ahora a esta
persona que le están imputando todos
todos estos
argumentos falaces el que ganó en el que
hizo un récord justamente de natación
mide menos en estatura el récord mundial
de mujeres y género en natación entonces
nuevamente se vuelve a fallar y les
dejen impedir sino si no transición
aaron antes de los 12 años entonces a
estas decisiones les tiene que saberla
las tomaron sin asesoría de personas
médicas expertas en la salud trans y fue
una decisión completamente
ignorante daniela también esto es todo a
pie y ya o pie para que otras
organizaciones de deporte internacional
se hayan pronunciado más o menos en esta
misma línea no de prohibiciones de
atletas trans en ligas de sobre todo
femeninas ustedes también tienen algo
preparado digamos o para responderle a
estados estas organizaciones
internacionales para tratar de revertir
estas medidas o para que otras
organizaciones internacionales de
deporte no tomen la misma de esta misma
medida que han tomado la fina o la liga
de hockey internacional
sí claro definitivamente mira todos los
días en la ciencia en la ciencia dura
real no en la pseudociencia hay un
montón de artículos publicados todos los
días por fortuna en septiembre y en el
congreso mundial de la w para esta
organización de médicos tratantes de la
salud trans
y en este hay una sección muy grande
sobre sobre deporte y personas trans
pero de nada sirve que tengamos un
montón de ejercicio científico de
mostrándole al mundo que la capacidad
muscular la capacidad ósea devuelven la
misma que una persona con ovarios o una
persona con testículos según la
transición de nada sirve que hagamos un
montón de información y los organismos
no tienen escuchar y no quieren tener
nuestra asesoría el gran problema es
justamente esto que toman sus decisiones
basados en sus preconceptos en sus
prejuicios en sus mitos y los estigmas
que nos atraviesan entonces está claro
que hay un montón de información todos
los días viene el congreso mundial ahí
va a ver mucha información
desmitificando todo esto pero si no nos
quieren escuchar cómo vamos a hacerlo
debería dar honor mismos como
superior que pudiera regular estas
decisiones asesorado justamente en
nuestra ciencia
daniela dessí daniela la decisión de la
fina
implica que se crea un grupo de trabajo
para estudiar la creación de una
categoría abierta donde puedan incluirse
los atletas trans más allá de los
géneros binarios masculino femenino que
es que forman la segmentación normal o
regular del deporte a ustedes les
satisface esta propuesta satisface la
digamos la necesidad de inclusión de los
atletas trans esta medida o es una forma
más de exclusión
y claro que es una forma más de
exclusión porque justo nos están
diciendo que estos lugares no nos
pertenecen y nos crean un lugar
separado para todas todos y todos
nosotros entonces claro que eso es una
nueva forma de exclusión es un parche la
problemática es un reto deportivo así lo
estamos calificando clasificando
porque justamente no nos están dando el
lugar que nos pertenece deberían
entender que estas clasificaciones
deportivas deberían darse
con base en y en relación a
el número de testosterona la cantidad de
testosterona y estrógenos y el tiempo de
estrógenos y testosterona
independientemente de tu genital porque
eso es lo que da un gran parte y en gran
medida la resistencia y la fuerza y la
capacidad muscular y ósea no tanto tu
genital o no tanto tu género social eso
no aporta realmente a tu desempeño
físico ya tu desempeño deportivo lo que
sí es que hormonas y cuánto tiempo
tienes con esta hormona en sangre eso es
decisivo eso es lo que deben de tomar en
cuenta no tu género social